but first tonight in the state of
California a man screaming obscenities
about the president attacked Republican
congressional candidate Rudy Peters over
the weekend he tried to stab him with a
switchblade meanwhile here in Washington
police are investigating an angry
progressive who apparently threatened to
shoot Trump supporters at the Trump
International Hotel the man had a
Twitter avatar promoting the Democratic
socialists of America at the University
of Southern Nevada meanwhile a sociology
professor called mark Byrd apparently
became so enraged by Trump that he
showed up at school with a gun he was
gonna stage some kind of protest in the
end he shot only himself in the arm
which may say more about his competence
than about anything else that's very
sort of amusing a sociology professor ,
of course but the larger trend is not
amusing at all the left is moving from
words to action and why wouldn't they
their heroes are encouraging it here's
congresswoman Maxine Waters of Los
Angeles boasting just days ago that she
threatens people she doesn't agree with
watch and of course the Lions resident
said that I had all of his constituents
his constituents supporters I do that
all the time but I didn't do at that
time well you'd think that just a little
over a year after a progressive activist
showed up with a rifle at a
congressional baseball practice to kill
Republicans and shot four people
Democratic officeholders would be wary
of talking like this but they're not
were their leaders Nancy Pelosi brags
that she will soon be Speaker of the
House again and she may be Bose he could
do a lot for this country by speaking
out against this ominous trend toward
violence it wouldn't take much just five
words political violence is never
justified political violence is never
justified hold a press conference and
say that repeat it with vehemence people
would listen you might even help Pelosi
politically doing the right thing
usually does help politically so we're
gonna wait and see if she does it Lou
Dobbs host Lou Dobbs tonight on Fox
Business and he joins us tonight Lou am
i imagining that this trend is real and
it's accelerating you're exactly right
and it is I it is deep
disturbing because there is a a certain
wink and nod that is taking place in the
Democratic Party because they are not
denouncing this kind of violence and it
is building whether it's on the streets
or whether it is in the University of
Southern Nevada or Maxine Waters
actually calling on on Democrats to
confront Republicans in restaurants
anywhere they find them this is this is
you know we kind of cutely call Trump
derangement syndrome this is far far
more than that this is there's nothing
trivial about this this is a threat
against our very political system so
Democrats are joiners their herd animals
they believe in the party in a way that
Republicans don't so if one of their
leaders if the incoming potentially
incoming speaker the house were to say
political violence is never justified
not hard that would probably have an
effect will she do that do you think I
don't think she would I I think it's too
convenient for her it is too convenient
for the left they are being pushed to
the radical day being the Democratic
Party are being pushed toward the
radical left at the farthest end of the
spectrum that is anyone in America has
ever witnessed this is a party right now
that is its establishment is threatened
by that leftward push from the
grassroots and by the way also from the
leaders of the Democratic National
Committee
Perez Ellison these are these are
radical left-wing Democrats and that is
where the party wants to be Nancy Pelosi
would be at once irrelevant and probably
trampled by the herd if she even
suggested such a thing so you're saying
that the establishment is afraid of its
own constituents it's afraid of the
crazies on its leftward flying oh
absolutely yeah and it's constituents
are the the Democratic Party has become
tribal in itself you know people talk
about tribalism within our society in
modern America but the Democratic Party
is built up of a concet of
constituencies that is warring with one
they don't quite trust each other and
they really don't quite know each other
and the result is it is a party without
discipline I it is a party without
concurrence about the policies and the
traditions and the values of the country
that they want to embrace and right now
they seem to be embracing none of them
so considering that Democrats could very
well win the house they're certainly
favored to win two months from right now
it matters this question which side
prevails so what is the Democratic Party
when the smoke clears I the Democratic
Party right now is is a socialist
organization I in the state of becoming
it is not appended to any of its history
right now are the issues that matter
working men and women in this country
the middle class they they seem to not
give a hoot about those traditional
concerns of the Democratic Party and
instead are become all about grievance
group and identity politics and where
that leads I certainly could not discern
never leads to a good place lou dobbs
thank you very much that analysis I
appreciate it great to be with